when it comes to diy we know that
mistakes
happen oh my goodness i've had so many
and we wanted to give
one diyer the chance to do a do-over
or as we call it a drew over
it's true okay this diy fail caught my
attention when it went viral on
tick-tock
minnesota art teacher shannon huber
attempted to give her bathroom a
makeover by creating an
accent wall using black paint and some
tape
but what she was left with was a diy
fail
that would have left every anyone
frazzled take a look
[Music]
shannon joins us now hi shannon hello
good to be here shannon what happened
oh well we purchased an older home
and my husband and i have been working
on redoing some things
and i had this vision of this really
cute accent wall
and so during my toddler's nap times i
spent
hours measuring with a ruler drawing
things out
taping um and then i decided to go bold
with a
black paint thinking that it would look
really neat with some
sharp white designs but when i took the
tape off it just
it didn't turn out at all the paint just
bled right through the tape and
um i did what any good millennial mom
would do when i posted it on tick tock
yeah well it got everybody's attention
including
ours but really that tape job i feel
like that was the art piece in itself
you should have just walked away and
dropped that tape you know what i mean
it was really
impressive well i wanted to invite
someone here today
to help show everyone how to paint
the wall and prevent another diy fail
so please welcome celebrity interior
designer and our good friend mikelle
welch
thank you for having me mikael
this is us in a series of many
adventures we are having together
yes it is but you know what shannon i
believe and i think drew as well we
believe in second chances right
if we didn't have them i wouldn't be
here so
we're gonna help you get it together
because uh
this was a little bit of a hot mess so
all right mo cal
tell us like teach us how to do this
yes okay so i'm gonna have you start on
this side because i know you're a
chevron girl i think you have something
like that similar
in your home right well shannon um one
time i had this like
patio outside of my dining room in los
angeles and when i got an
estimate to tyler it was so expensive
and i was like
no so i taped it out and i painted it
oh you did that yourself no oh
girl i was about to be really impressed
i know
i didn't do it but i was i looked at the
bill for tyle and i was like there's got
to be a better way
so i came up with the idea for the pain
and then i asked my friend to paint it
okay well listen i feel like after this
you're going to be good shannon's going
to be good
everybody in america is going to be able
to do this really simple and easy all
right so
this is this is what we're going to do
you ready you ready yes
all right so we're going to start with
our initial wall that we have right here
so
first we're gonna meticulously uh
carve out what we're gonna do with that
painters tape so you've got your chevron
i've got my herringbone
everything is charted out with our
pencil we had to use a little bit of
math and we've got it good to go right
yes yes all right so what i would like
for you to do over there drew is i want
you to go ahead
and i want you to paint your wall white
and the reason you're painting it white
because that's the base color of your
wall
so whatever we paint initially this is
going to seal
the tape how are you feeling over there
drew i
am so happy and shannon i want to ask
you a question which is
like did you know or had you ever heard
to do this
step in the process i must say no
no i i ha if i had i would have done it
yeah i promise you this portion is going
to be life-changing for you so
you can kind of see where we're going
with this right you've got like the
whole little rhythm to
it okay so with our tv magic you've got
your second piece
of the equation right here and then now
you want to take the
other color that you want to be the
prominent color
and we're going to place that on top of
the white that we've painted
mikael this is so groundbreaking all
right i'm telling you it's going to work
shannon are you still with me i am okay
i'm making sure
because i want you to send me pictures
before you put this thing on tick tock
we want to make sure that you got it
right
all right so now we've gotten down to
the last part so this is where we want
to go ahead and remove the tape
and what i'm going to do is pull my
piece right from the seam
like i call it the spine basically and
go really slow
like you've taken hours to chart this
out it's no reason to rush but you can
see
how clean well at least my lines are
really clean are yours coming out
clearly they're coming out very clean
macau and that's also something i don't
i was nervous slow
[Music]
slow look at that man slow
all right mine's just looking pretty
good i mean i am
really excited mikal i feel like this
looks super
professional it does it's incredibly
gratifying
all right shannon you feeling empowered
up there
absolutely i'm ready to go try this
again i have lots of walls at my house
okay okay mikael your wall
is amazing yours is too
shannon is this the kind of result that
you were hoping for
definitely this is what i was looking
for from the beginning
well you clearly know how to do it
because we saw you tape it out michael
has now given us the secret to
success and guess what we have
macall approved design patterns that you
can print out
on the drewberrymore show.com to inspire
an accent while in your home
macau has worked with some of the
biggest names in the business and now
you can have his mastery right
in your home so thank you mikael
of course and thank you for showing us
the way of course
what do you think shannon i love it it's
amazing all right well let's get a brand
new tick tock going with all of us i
like that
and right that's wrong thank you mikael
thank you for having me always your wall
looks so good shannon
thank you so much for coming on our show
after you're a big
tick tock moment and we'd love to do
another one with you thank you